the myos Briggs type indicator is a
self-assessment of how we perceive the
world and make decisions
the test measures our preferences in
four domains sources of mental energy
processing of information approach to
decision making and need for structure
each of the four categories has two
sides extraversion or introversion
sensing or intuition
thinking or feeling and judging or
perceiving
this then results in 16 possible
personality types
before we begin the test keep three
things in mind human traits exist on a
spectrum you could fall in the center of
two extremes and get different results
when repeating the test later the mbti
looks at preferences so people who
prefer extroversion over introversion
may not be extroverts they simply like
that personality type better don't take
the results too seriously
to determine your type ask yourself
these four questions
do you focus outwardly or inwardly are
you rather outgoing or private do you
speak impulsively or thoughtfully
do you get energized being around others
or do you recharge alone
do you prefer extroversion or
introversion
how do you prefer to take in information
do you focus on how things are or
imagine how things could be do you pay
attention to concrete details or do you
see the big picture do you prefer
practical ideas or enjoy theories for
their own sake do you favor sensing or
intuition
how do you like to make decisions do you
rely on logic or personal values do you
prioritize fairness and Justice or
forgiveness and harmony
do you enjoy finding flaws in arguments
or agreeing with others
do you like thinking or feeling
how do you prefer to live your outer
life do you want matters settled or
options open do you think rules need to
be respected or see them as suggestions
do you like detailed instructions or
prefer improvisation do you like judging
or perceiving
foreign
who you are you can take the letters
representing extroversion introversion
sensing intuition thinking feeling
judging and perceiving and form your
type say ESTJ
what that means becomes clear when we
look at the 16 personality types
estps enjoy being around people and
focus on the Here and Now their minds
are quick intelligent and outspoken good
at reading others they can solve complex
problems routines bore them and they see
rules as recommendations they are often
called doers
estjs prefer things settled and are not
interested in abstract ideas they value
security and are also known as Guardians
at work they are capable of organizing
getting things done and a loyal
colleagues who don't miss small
important details to keep things neat
they want everyone to follow the
protocol
esfps a friendly social and accepting
they love to have new experiences and
meet new people esfps enjoy seeing
others happy and as a result are often
the center of attention
disliking analysis they have plenty of
Common Sense instead of logic they are
driven by values and hence tend to agree
with people they like they are also
called performers
esfjs are warm-hearted and Cooperative
they feel a strong sense of Duty value
traditions and are loyal friends at work
they are detailed and tend to complete
tasks accurately and on time their
empathy allows them to see what others
need which makes them good leaders
esfjs want to be appreciated for who
they are and are known as caregivers
enfps are known as enthusiastic
idealists who see a life full of
possibilities their minds are
spontaneous creative and are able to do
almost anything that interests them
although the affirmation of their peers
greatly influences their behavior at
work enfps are fast thinkers and good at
improvising but they do get bored with
details or things they don't care about
some call them Inspire us
enfjs are warm responsive and able to
take responsibility they show
outstanding people skills and see plenty
of potential in others
this makes them good managers and
inspiring leaders since they are
concerned about how others think and
feel they are also known as givers
entps are intellectually quick creative
and good at a broad range of things they
get excited about new projects but are
so bored by routines that they rarely do
the same thing the same way their
ability to read others think
strategically and solve complex problems
makes them stimulating friends some call
them Visionaries
entjs tend to be confident Frank and
quick to make a decision they value
competence and have no patience for
nonsense at work they are quick to spot
poor organizational design and are able
to create intelligent new solutions they
like to make long-term plans and then
Implement them no matter what that's one
reason some call them executives
and now those who prefer introverts
istjs are calm serious and interested in
peaceful living their judgment is
thorough and realistic they like to keep
things organized a hard-working and are
focused on achieving what they set out
to
the fact that they are loyal reliable
and detailed gave them the nickname
inspectors
istps are reserved and relaxed until
there is a problem then they act quickly
and usually find a good solution their
curiosity about how things work makes
them good analysts and great Engineers
their thinking is structured and logical
but not afraid to break the rules if
they get in the way of them doing
something extraordinary they are known
as the mechanics
isfjs are introverts that are
conscientious and kind they often have a
high degree of empathy and remember
specifics about their friends at work
they are committed to meeting their
obligations and like to see everyone
happy
interested in serving others they are
called nurturers
isfps are serious sensitive and
good-hearted they are very loyal friends
and committed to their personal values
conflicts stress them out which is why
they don't like to lead or control
others their sense of time and
appreciation for beauty gave them the
Alias artists
INFJs a sensitive original and the
rarest of all types their strong
intuition means that they trust their
instincts above all else they prefer
neither leading nor following but doing
what feels right their Devotion to
protecting what they value earned them
the pseudonym Defenders
infps are reflective loyal and often
idealistic their primary goal is to find
out their meaning in life to make the
world a better place at work they like
to help and a quick to spot
possibilities to make things better
interested in serving Humanity they are
also called idealists
intjs have mines that are original
independent and analytical at work they
think long term are determined and show
a high standard of competence for
themselves and others this makes them
natural leaders their knowledge and
cognitive ability gave them the Alias
scientists
intps are creative and rational and get
excited about theories and ideas their
tendency to be quiet makes them hard to
read although when they focus on
problems they find interesting they
often reveal their true character they
have natural skepticism and logical
explanations for almost everything they
are called thinkers
the building blocks of the original mbti
were laid by Catherine Briggs and her
daughter Isabelle Briggs Myers who based
their work on Carl Jung's influential
1921 theory of psychological types
what do you think can we divide
individuals into 2 4 8 or 16 personality
types and then infer who they are share
your thoughts in the comments below to
do an mbti test right now look for the
link in the description
[Music]
foreign
if you found this helpful check out our
other videos and subscribe if you want
to support our work join us on
patreon.com sprouts for more information
and additional content visit
sproutschools.com